Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
So, a Youtube employee once told me
that almost all so-called low-engagement viewers
decide whether to watch a video in the first 12 seconds.
And I don't want any low-engagement viewers today, hence the 12 seconds of silence.
Also, how long is 12 seconds
of silence on YouTube? An eternity!
By the way, Hank, I'm in Amsterdam.
This is not a green screen or anything.
It only looks impossibly beautiful.
But anyway, the easiest and most obvious metric
for successful YouTube videos
is how many views it gets, and lately,
ours have been getting a lot of views.
In the past month our new videos have averaged over 600,000 views.
Meanwhile, a lot of other things are also
increasing the size of nerdfighteria.
By the way, in a stunning turn of events,
it is raining in Amsterdam.
So, I think I'm going to go inside.
Rain's relationship with Amsterdam is like mine.
It visited once and it was like "This is great,"
and then it kept coming back.
This is better.
So nerdfighteria is growing in lots of ways.
My books are reaching a much larger audience
than I ever imagined.
I mean, Hank, I now regularly get emails
in all capital letters from 80-year-old grandmothers
that are like, "My granddaughter told me to read your book, and I did, and I liked it.
And now my entire retirement home's book club is reading it.
P.S. What happens to Anna's mom?"
And that's awesome because A,
we need more old people in nerdfighteria
and B, it's good to know that 80-year-olds
and teenagers ask the same questions.
Also, Crash Course and SciShow and Mental Floss
all have large and growing audiences,
and the very way
that we find Youtube videos is changing.
I mean, having a feed instead of a subscription box
means that we see more videos
from channels we aren't subscribed to
and fewer from the ones we are subscribed to.
So, here's my fear Hank: As communities grow,
especially if they grow without deepening,
they paradoxically often become less important.
Like, a lot of people watch the television program,
"Two and a Half Men,"
but that show's community
is far less interesting and important
than a much less popular show, like "Supernatural."
Now, of course, bigger doesn't always
mean less important.
The Harry Potter books, for instance,
reached a fairly large audience.
But still, that core community of Potter fans
who listened to Wizard Rock
and started the Harry Potter Alliance
made big and lasting changes in the world,
and they're still making them.
In short, Hank, if we're going to keep growing,
I want to make sure that we grow like that.
So, Hank, we realized several years ago
that fame isn't very fulfilling.
But what is tremendously fulfilling is the opportunity
to make stuff you like with people you like.
So, I want to make that recommitment to nerdfighteria
that this is truly a collaboration among all of us.
I think we should continue to make videos that explain stuff like health care costs and sovereign debt
and the war in Syria, and I also think we should
make videos about stuff that we care about
like the TFIOS movie, which I care about very much.
But Hank, I also want to be making good and funny
and nerdy stuff with nerdfighteria.
So, let's start today.
My last video was over four minutes long.
Nerdfighters in Our Pants,
which sounds dirty, but isn't,
decided that it did not meet the definition
of an educational video,
ergo, I am punished!
By the way, for those of you
who are new,
Our Pants is the forum.
Our videos aren't allowed to be more
than four minutes long unless they're educational.
Hank is my brother.
I like pizza.
Hank likes corn dogs, and nerdfighters are nerds
who fight to make the world suck less.
Also, Hank, according to the nerdfighters in Our Pants,
we both already owe punishments,
so we're both punished,
and I'm doubly punished.
So nerdfighters, we need lots
of punishment suggestions in comments.
Hank, thanks for the update video,
which might be even better than 12 seconds of silence
at getting non-nerdfighters to stop watching.
I'm very excited for Emma Approved by the way, and I will see you on Friday.